hi I'm Harrison Ford I'm here to talk
about call of the wild and to play with
puppies
bring on the puppy
[Music]
Hey
hey buddy
[Music]
are you talking to me are you talking to
him yeah I knew the book I read it when
I was in high school and I thought it
was really interesting and powerful I
thought that there was a great story to
tell we changed the book a little bit
and I'm very happy with the film the
chance to play with puppies now I've
always had dogs we have three dogs now
in my house this dog up for adoption I
think there's a real positive story of
human Redemption and celebration of
nature those are two wonderful
experiences oh I don't I don't think I
want to go back and redo anything that
I've done I've had great experiences
thing about the movie business is you
work with different people on different
subjects and you and I'm getting chewed
it's an adventure every time and I love
that about it it's better than a real
job the complete and utter disdain that
that our very experienced British crew
felt for what we were doing is what I
mean we're they couldn't figure it out
guy running her on and the dogs suitor
and princess and some guys in tight
pants it didn't they couldn't figure out
what we're doing
so they laughed at us constantly for we
were ridiculous and we were but we made
a movie that people really enjoyed
steal props no I wouldn't do that but
took away memories
I got into carpentry when I bought a
house that I wanted to remodel and then
ran out of money buying tools and didn't
have enough money for materials so I
went out and got a job as a carpenter I
educated myself from books from the
library and became a carpenter and I
really enjoyed the experience of working
with wood with people with designs gave
me a way another way of making a living
and so gave me some options I didn't I
didn't lose my ambition I didn't change
my ambition to to be an actor I just was
finding a different way of putting food
on the table and therefore giving myself
more choices
they're all me more or less right right
Oh Kerry was a lot of fun she was really
smart she was really funny good person a
lot of a lot of memories of Kerry oh wow
it's not the years it's the mileage
I don't think anything's underrated just
misunderstood study the script to figure
out who the character is learn about
their lives
car thief the puppies are playing with
today are from Pacific pups rescue for
more information about them but a
Pacific pups rescued calm give these
guys at home you'll be happy it is yeah
[Music]
[Music]